la parole est au président bruno
retailleau pour le vent plus républicain
pour deux minutes
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues monsieur le premier ministre à
mon tour et au nom du groupe l'est
républicain je voudrais dire au peuple
allemand à la fois notre compassion
notre solidarité après ce qui s'est
passé hier c'est parce que la france les
français notre pays a subi le même drame
avec les mêmes modalités que aujourd'hui
nous nous sentons un peu et tous
berlinois évidemment et à nouveau nous
le voyons bien le barbare la barbarie
islamiste a frappé ce terrorisme qui
vient du fond de la nuit sans âge des
violences barbares a à nouveau frappé
des pays et cette cruauté ces crimes
nous rappelle que cette violence est
implacable elle nous rappelle aussi que
cette violence à deux formes une forme
mondiale une forme total mondial puisque
sur le 1er semestre de cette année
seulement
on a dénombré pas moins de 550 attentes
à 5 105 ans et trois par jour avec des
milliers de victimes
sur les cinq continents sa forme est
aussi totale parce que il y a les deux
fronts le front extérieur sur lequel
opère nos soldats auxquels je veux
rendre hommage le front intérieur sur
lequel opèrent toutes les forces de
l'ordre je veux aussi leur rendre
évidemment hommage mais on le voit bien
à chaque fois ces frappes tous des
symboles tous les symboles de ce que
nous sommes
le président du sénat il ya quelques
instants le collègue du parti socialiste
appuyé sur l'exemple allemand des
marchés de noël
nous avons été touchés dans notre fête
nationale les valeurs de la république
nous avons été touchés aussi avec un
prêtre égorgé nos racines spirituelles
ce totalitarisme vise évidemment ce que
nous sommes et nous devons lui répondre
et nous avons monsieur le premier
ministre
évidemment un devoir une certitude c'est
que une fois que nous aurons vaincu
l'état islamique
tout cela ne s'arrêtera pas c'est
beaucoup plus difficile vous le savez
bien et nous partageons cette conviction
je crois que c'est une idéologie vie au
delà d'un territoire et nous avons une
conviction c'est que la france doit être
implacables au moment où des djihadistes
vont être caution de mossoul et
peut-être de jaca demain quels
dispositifs monsieur le premier ministre
comptez vous prendre pour protéger les
français monsieur le premier ministre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président caillot
merci d'abord pour les mots que vous
venez d'avoir de solidarité à l'égard du
peuple allemand dans l'épreuve terrible
à laquelle ils se trouvent confrontés et
qui fait écho à la tragédie à laquelle
notre peur propre peuple a dû faire face
et je pense notamment au tragique
attentat à tunis le jour de la fête
nationale
vous avez eu raison d'évoquer que toutes
nos forces sont mobilisés que nous avons
jeté toute notre énergie dans cette
bataille contre le terrorisme nous
sommes présents à l'extérieur nous
sommes présents dans la coalition en
irak et en syrie
nous avons frappé le terrorisme dans ces
pays
nous l'avons fait avec la détermination
de la coalition mais aussi nous l'avons
fait en dehors de l'irak et de la syrie
lorsque les valeurs essentielles
auxquelles notre pays est attaché et qui
font civilisations ont été mises en
cause par des terroristes avec
l'abjection les exactions que l'on sait
au mali notamment où le président de la
république a décidé de l'intervention de
nos militaires et je veux leur rendre
hommage pour le travail qu'ils
accomplissent pour la parole de la
france qu'il porte à travers leur
engagement sur le théâtre des opérations
extérieures et dire aussi à la
représentation nationale qu'à travers
l'engagement de nos soldats c'est la
détermination de la france à gagner la
guerre contre le terrorisme qui
s'exprime avec une résolution une
fermeté absolue
le deuxième point sur lequel je voudrais
insister c'est sur le fait que face à
l'islamisme radical
face à la barbarie face à la volonté de
s'en prendre à ce qu'est l'europe à ce
que sont les peuples d'europe dans leurs
modalités de vie c'est à dire la liberté
la fraternité le plaisir d'être ensemble
dans la concorde et la tolérance il n'ya
qu'une réponse monsieur le président
otayo
c'est une fermeté absolue c'est cette
fermeté qui nous conduit à fermer des
lieux de culte lorsqu'au sein de ces
lieux de culte il est proféré une
conception de l'islam qui est
orthogonale de ce que sont tous les
principes de la république et ce sont
une vingtaine de lieux de culte que nous
avons fermé au cours des derniers mois
ça veut dire expulsé ce qui est étrange
et porte une parole qui est complètement
contraire à toutes les valeurs qui nous
rassemblent par delà ce qui peut nous
différencier dans cet hémicycle
c'est l'expulsion de 80 personnes depuis
quelques mois parce que ces personnes
appelées et provoqué au terrorisme ou à
la haine dans leurs interventions dans
des lieux de culte dans l'espace public
ou sur internet
c'est la fermeture résolu des sites qui
provoque et appelle au terrorisme c'est
le travail que nous avons engagée au
sein du réseau ran européen ou avec les
opérateurs internet pour faire en sorte
que tous les messages qui peuvent
influencer les plus vulnérables de nos
compatriotes en les conduisant à
commettre des crimes abjects soit
immédiatement retiré de la toile et que
l'on puisse ainsi par un travail de
sensibilisation et de développement du
contrôle discours nous armés face à la
propagande pernicieuse des terroristes
c'est ce que nous avons fait aussi
monsieur le président en redonnant
beaucoup de moyens nos forces de
sécurité si le président de la
république et mon prédécesseur manuel
valls ont décidé de créer près de 9000
emplois dans les forces de sécurité
intérieure dont 2000 ont été affectés
aux services de renseignements c'est
bien parce que nous ressentions la
nécessité de réarmer la république
face à cette menace terroriste si nous
avons décidé d'augmenter de 18% les
moyens d'investissement de ses forces
pour qu'elles aient des véhicules des
moyens numériques des moyens
d'investigation qui leur faisait défaut
c'est précisément parce que nous sommes
parfaitement conscients de la nécessité
de rehausser la république et ses moyens
face aux risques de terrorisme
si nous avons voté un certain nombre de
textes et vous avez été monsieur le
président otayo avec votre groupe en
soutien de ses textes
je pense à la loi sur le renseignement
je pense à l'état d'urgence c'est
précisément parce que nous étions
ensemble dans la conscience que la
menace terroriste appelée des mesures
dans le rassemblement de toutes les
forces de la république parce que la
capacité de la résilience de notre pays
de la nation dépend aussi de la capacité
que nous avons à nous rassembler lorsque
l'essentiel est en jeu
et puis il ya le déploiement de toutes
ses forces aujourd'hui sur le territoire
national pour assurer la protection des
français pour leur permettre de
continuer à vivre comme ils ont plaisir
et l'habitude de vivre parce que la
france doit demeurer la france et je
voudrais conclure par un mot ce que je
ne veux pas être trop long et qu'il ya
d'autres questions
vous évoquez ce à quoi les terroristes
s'en prennent mais ce à quoi les
terroristes s'en prennent en france et
peut-être en france plus que partout
ailleurs c'est à la belle idée de
république avec les valeurs qu'elle
porte et notamment la valeur de laïcité
c'est à dire la possibilité de croire ou
de ne pas croire est dès lors que l'on a
fait le choix de sa croyance d'être
garanti par la république qu'on pourra
l'exercer librement et qu'à ce titre
d'ailleurs
la contrepartie de la possibilité de
liberté d'exercice de chaque culte
suppose que chacun qui a une croyance
reconnaissent les valeurs de la
république comme transcendante de cette
croyance et s'engage à ne jamais les
remettre en cause parce que les en le
remontant en cause c'est tout
l'équilibré républicain qui se trouve
compromis
c'est ça la république c'est ça l'unité
et l'indivisibilité de la république
c'est ça la belle idée de la république
et c'est cela aussi que nous devons
porter face à nos concitoyens pour que
ceux qui veulent semer la division en
france trouve en face d'eux la puissance
d'une conception de l'humanisme des
relations humaines de la fraternité et
de la concorde
la parole est à notre collègue vincent
eblé